das land leidet ist zerrissen ob der
frage wie viel fremdes platz haben soll
im vertrauten in sankt moritz liegt der
mann begraben der den politischen kampf
gegen das fremde eröffnet hat james
schwarzenbach
er formte ende der 60er jahre in der
schweiz die erste fremdenfeindliche
partei in nordeuropa wer mag kann das
als historisches verdienst betrachten
schwarzenbach war ein eigenartiger kaum
fassbarer mensch und doch konnte er
einige jahre lang das halbe volk hinter
sich scharen
das problem bestand hätte rand und wie
politik bemüht entweder macht derzeit
ich mache 60 mache selber mit dem mit
dem volk für mich ist schwarzenbach
saale begnadete redner sie aber der
großen egozentrischen harry reid und
typischen sie dixie also musste die
naschi schwarzenbach einer vater damals
richter familie des schmiedens
ideologisch sehr vorsichtig
schwarzenbach eine bemühte gehandelt
[Musik]
es waren die 60er jahren
die schweiz war vom krieg verschont
geblieben
und ein entfesseltes wirtschaftswunder
verlangt danach zupackenden händen
so wurden fremdarbeiter vor allem
italiener in großer zahl ins land
gerufen
meist an solche arbeitsplätze die den
schweizern nicht beharken
beispielsweise in den gotthard 1970 mit
dem bau des längsten straßentunnels der
welt begonnen wurde
270 der 300 arbeiter waren ausländer
die schweiz wie wir sie auch heute noch
kennen wurde von ausländern gebaut
[Musik]
bis zu jenen jahren waren die
einheimischen schulkinder weitgehend
unter sich
doch nun saß ab und zu auch ein
italienisches kind zwischen den
schweizer schülern und oft mussten sich
diese kleinen zuzüger sehr fremd fühlen
wie eine lehrerin damals schilderte
[Musik]
loris scola war ein solches
italienisches mädchen
sie war zehn jahre alt als sie 1962 mit
mutter und bruder zum vater nach zürich
zurück dieser hatte zuvor in der schweiz
bereits mehrere jahre als saisonnier auf
dem bau gearbeitet danke so abgelehnt
und bin ich hoch und das ist stimmig sie
ein haus gegenüber allem fremden und
melitta jänner sind dann die fremde xi
und sie haben uns jeden tag spürt dass
das doch loris wollte nicht anders sein
als die schweizer kinder
sie litt darunter als fremde angesehen
zu werden
es hat nicht gemerkt dass ich muss nicht
schweizer lehrt ich darf nur italiener
im blieb und dass ich mich angeschaut
dann für millimeter wasser italienisches
gesehen hat und einmal auf der straße
wenig exakt die an der siebte gang menü
mutter will ich danke an dann hört er
sich zu ihren gehöre und das hat mich
dann wahnsinnig traurig gemacht und ich
habe mit der mutter über das können die
räder und sie hat das sehr gut verstand
schnell lernte loris deutsch
bald war sie eine der klassenbesten doch
das reichte dem lehrer nicht
wieder saß hat der primarschule jeder zu
mir gesagt jetzt haben wir mal für den
landesliga wo du hund und und habe mich
dann gefragt was schafft ihm vater
untersagte die schmuddel offenburg
und noch einer hat gesagt was wurde von
bookassist realschule und die hatten mit
news hat sammelklagen class und zur burg
sie juristisch cola schaffte es trotzdem
und wurde mathematik lehrerin im
zürcherischen meilen wo sie die
primarschule besucht hat erinnert sich
die italienische sekunde an ihrer ersten
schweizer jahre und an ihrer
verwirkliche begegnung mit der zürcher
mundart die weltmeister beim druck stand
wo nicht oben sind die schimpfwörter sie
und die sie mir ganz durchgegangen und
die harmonie wieder zeit ohne zu wissen
was die heiße und dann hat die
realschullehrerin mahlzeit aber lewis
frank mastiaux nein das ist sagt jetzt
nochmals schlafsäcke und das hat ja was
das heißen kann hat er mir erklärt was
das heißt und am schluss sein
grausamer waren die erlebnisse auf dem
schulhausplatz loris und ihr bruder
waren hier in ober meilen die ersten
italienischen kinder und das bekamen sie
zu spüren
am mittwochnachmittag und dann noch ein
4 die sie mit der mutter auf dem
schulhausplatz cohen hat viele spiele
miteinander hin und gewinnt aber nicht
schlagen so dass ich nach ein blogger
kann und muss
und die hatten eine weile da blieben und
sich sehr herzlich und für die ganze
familie
[Musik]
die unterkünfte der fremdarbeiter waren
oft erbärmlich menschenunwürdig auf
engstem raum wurden die saison je in
baracken und abbruch häuser gepfercht
[Musik]
auch die familie ist cola von vorerst
nur in einem keller unterschlupf mit
schlafplätzen unter dem dach und auch
dies nur weil das haus der textilfabrik
gehört er in welcher die mutter
arbeitete das ich gesehen dass ich hier
dass jedes gericht ziehen
er sei froh dass es als luis scola 23
jahre alt war ließ sich in meilen ein
bürgern als auch bedarf weile und zum
eintrat und da hat es sind sie dass ich
so gut zurecht kommen und dann hand seit
sie wählt jetzt k frage stelle zur
schweizer geschichte aber ich muss da
gewährte hätte dann sehen wo gerade ein
blumenstock vor sich her und dann habe
ich das gewusst dass ich der christoph
blocher sie warnt auch vor den
kantonsrat gewählt worden ist unter sind
ganze stunde sie haben also kenntnis und
christoph blocher den sozialgerichten
die schweiz im jahre 1970 wirtschaftlich
ein gesegnetes land 0 prozent betrug die
arbeitslosenquote durch die starke
zuwanderung verursachte ein unbehagen in
teilen der heimischen bevölkerung knapp
eine million ausländer lebten und
arbeiteten damals in der schweiz die
hälfte davon italiener also das land
hätte eigentlich kein problem
1970 die beiden dominierenden
innenpolitische thema singt sie durchs
land frack und damit verbundene muss
sich das auf der zunge zur baukonjunktur
dämpfung das heißt geschäft sind so gut
gegangen dass die inflation beschossen
und dann hätte politik müsse die griffe
doch der boom schuf auch verlierer
schweizer sahen sich als mieter und am
arbeitsplatz von ausländern
konkurrenziert
da tauchte dieser mann auf james
schwarzenbach aus reicher zürcher
industriellen familie ein erfolgloser
verleger der national konservative
intellektuelle erkannte seine chance
politische bedeutung zu erlangen
als dominierende figur der
ausländerfeindliche nationalen aktion
brachte er die erste initiative gegen
die überfremdung die nach ihm benannte
schwarzenbach initiative an die urne
[Musik]
gewerkschafter helmut hubacher
langjähriger präsident der schweizer
sozialdemokraten war dann bis schwarzen
mach's gegenspieler nachtrab steht nicht
wo sie zunächst redaktion heute über den
zürichsee sein geschäft seit die
russland initiative das ist die chance
meines lebens berühmt zu werden
und da ist in italien fand sie die seite
ganz büros mit italienischer bildes
kultur bestückte chance warum wurde
plötzlich italien immer vorbild sie es
ist die chance meines lebens berühmt zu
werden und die chance weitere nutzt
unterrichtet worden
herrischried kss in richtung klartext
züge mit die steckdose wie sich das
verbessere hergehört und erhöhten arten
sarkastischer humor kann man aber
gemerkt hat eigentlich verachtet er
seine gefolgschaft
er braucht sie aber verachtet sie
zum ersten mal waren in der schweiz die
ausländer politisch zum problem erhoben
worden
schwarzenbach trat meist als
einzelkämpfer auf wenn er an den
zahlreichen veranstaltungen im lande
seine forderungen die sanfter stimme und
demagogischer kraft vertrag in diesen
debatten war ihm kaum jemand gewachsen
warum kümmert sich die herren so ganz
ausschließlich und russland bestand
warum kritisieren mitglieder intensität
um der schweizerische arbeitnehmer
[Applaus]
nationalrat mit dem salvatore und mit
dem atom hofheimer schaffte es ist die
ganze kenntnis
[Musik]
einmal hat einen schwierigen mit den
trassen zur post und die herren von
messi zum ist schon so lange soll ich
sagen es gibt situationen wo und sie
haben die wahl ob sie mit james
schwarzenbach die ein verwaltungsakt
findet wie ein
die funktechnologie und sie haben mir
nach 17 allen mitteilen sie habe mit ihm
einen verwaltungsrat kunden ich bin
glücklich allawi kein sie da bin ich
einmal an freie manchen grad initiative
betrachten
nein james schwarzenbach musste nie für
geld arbeiten nicht mal in eine
verwaltungsrat seine schwester rosemary
erinnerte sich im jahre 2005 an ihren
berühmten bruder vielleicht heben
er hat das hauptfeld als dass sie damit
richtig geld verdienen
überall waren sie nun diese ausländer so
schien es vielen schweizern und sie
sahen ihre eigene lebensweise ihre
identität bedroht
[Musik]
schwarzenbach initiative forderte dass
der anteil der ausländer nicht mehr als
zehn prozent der bevölkerung betragen
dürfe bei einer annahme der initiative
hätten über 300.000 ausländer vor allem
italiener die schweiz verlassen müssen
für die schweizer industrie die 35
prozent ausländer beschäftigte stellte
diese initiative eine existenzielle
bedrohung dar
in gewissen industriezweigen gießereien
etwa fanden sich kaum mehr schweizer
arbeiter die ausländischen arbeiter wo
man bio ist ein traum - ihr
verschiedener länder würden sie
differenzieren noch qualität und
eigentlich zur assimilation oder würden
sie alles über dich leichter
während die initiative zwar bewusst mir
redet nicht für einzelne länder sondern
mir sagen russland bestand also das
trifft das trifft ja sagte ali traf
aber wann es nun gerade als südländische
nachbar frauen betont dass traf ihr
italiener hat so stimmt dass wenn der
größte teil italiener sind und nun
möchte sagen das problem ist sicher
besonders groß wurde
wenn wir nicht wie anfangs der 80er
jahre
norditaliener bos kann die der große zu
hause und weil mir übt sie die italiener
in der großzahl hand wenn die initiative
vom schweizer volk wird dann steht
dahinter bestimmt aus großes sage von
der schule von der schule und nach toren
von bewahren der schönen schweiz
gerettet und du und alle schüler von
anderen gewarnt hat schwarzenbach auf
dem schlachtfeld
von sempach schweizer erwarten bis das
leben der nationalen aktion und weckte
auch jene die sich darob an den kampf
ruf der deutschen nationalsozialisten
erinnert sein
schwarzenbach der konvertierte ultra
konservative katholik hegte sympathien
für diktatoren und faschismus wie er in
späteren jahren offen eingestanden
extratour strahlen schlacht finde tätige
überhaupt die diktatur schlacht und
demokratie freuen dass leipzig schön ab
werk in der schweiz wäre diktatur visier
haben
wenn wir sind das geeignete land für
demokratie wir herrn nach überschaubare
kontrollierbare verhältnis würde sie
sich als faschist bezeichnen ein
schweizer akw schließlich demokratie
aber wenn sie entspannen würde glaube
dann werden sie wäre wahnsinn eine
schwarzen wachs kampf einer gegen alle
gegen alle anderen parteien gegen kirche
und wirtschaft
doch allein war schwarzenbach nicht denn
nach der versteckte ängste entdeckt
schlummernder instinkte geweckt der
abstimmungskampf verlief äußerst
emotional
aggressiv
das ist sich stimmig sie im drum mine
hat den schweizer zeit
dies solle den widerruf italien verreise
und mir sind tränen aber kommt und hat
dank diverser landläufig und am
hauptbahnhof sind italiener gegen die
schweizer die an diskutiert und wir
angst übersieht sie ist sich sicher die
zeit
naja und machen sie doch touristen stört
0 gleichen aktion sammel sich mit
notebook lernen hatte lernte damals fünf
jetzt diese monster und damit zwar
keinem land
der siebte juni 1970 der tag der
abstimmung der abrechnung
der streit über die angebliche
überfremdung hatte einen ansturm auf die
wahllokale veranlasst die
stimmbeteiligung war mit 74 rekordhoch
zur abstimmung zugelassen waren
allerdings nur männer
das frauenstimmrecht kam erst ein jahr
später
[Musik]
sieben kantone nahmen die initiative an
die übrigen verwarfen 46 prozent hatten
der initiative zugestimmt
ein unerwartet hoher jahr anteil 54
prozent hatten schwarzen bugs begehren
abgelehnt
[Musik]
absolut überrascht ich sie verdankt dass
der sachse fürs prozent ja-stimmen macht
das klima höflich und das hätte in einer
gruft zeigt die thematik wie brisant
dass die russland gefragt plötzlich
wurde nicht ich erscheine wissen heute
erinnere oder schwarze macht mit seiner
politischen aktionen mit der ausländer
initiative und weil er hat das vorrang
ist das für mich kein großes thema sie
die schlacht war geschlagen und knapp
entschieden
doch das land war fortan und ist es bis
heute geteilt in der frage wie mit der
emigration zu verfahren sei im berner
bundesparlament hatte es genau eine
stimme für die überfremdung initiative
gegeben
jene von nationalrat schwarzenbach alle
übrigen parlamentarier hatten nein
gesagt oder sich der stimme enthalten
schwarzenbach der einzelkämpfer hatte
die gleichgesinnten hier gefunden
an den berg plätzen oder schweizer sich
von ausländern bedrängt sagen
gewerkschafter helmut hubacher durfte
nach der abstimmung einen blick in
schwarzenbach spenderliste werfen voll
spannender 25 franken als auch lina lüth
eine weh tat um sich franke balogh
führen von der sbb st galler sp mitglied
und kantonsrat bin durch zusammenhang
allah will wissen wieso die antwort ist
oder die fuchsie schwarzenbacher draxler
das trauma der linken von 1970 damals
verlor sie dauerhaft einen teil ihrer
leute an die rechte
also ist völlig klar sie mit lena die
initiativen haben aber pflicht sieht die
gremien und ihrer show und zita ich das
so bliebe schock wirst mit seiner für
die halt ich politisch ganzen euro
preisvorteil von der arbeitnehmerschaft
versteigt das heimlich aufnahmen politik
unterstütze warum schwarzer waren oder
jetzt lockerer höchster bezahle für die
anstehende gewaltig bürgerpreis
[Musik]
von la spezia nach bern neun stunden
dauerte die reise in eine bessere
zukunft
1963 kam sehr giovanelli in die schweiz
28 jährige körperlich leicht behindert
und mit geringer schulbildung das neue
leben begann ganz unten mit
hilfsarbeiten in küche und garten der
giovanelli war einer gewalttätigen
familie entronnen und einer
kriegsversehrten heimat
heute lebt er zusammen mit seiner frau
judith in b
[Musik]
die komme werde um freiwilligentag
wir wollten das wunder von italien
wechseln beruflich konnte sich sehr
giovanelli allmählich verbessern
einen teil des lohnes schickte er der
mann nach hause
den anderen steckte er in seine bildung
die zeit der schwarzenbach abstimmung
bleibt ihm unvergesslich wie wade
konfrontiert mit dieser hass blicke
diese struktur und diese ablehnung ihrer
verachtung mit ware konfrontiert würde
gingen sie damit um wie wirkte das auf
sie mit 43 jahren verliebte sich sergio
vannelli in judith blocher eine
selbstbewusste frau sozialarbeiterin von
beruf schwester von christoph blocher
natürlich auch sie war konfrontiert mit
den vorurteilen gegenüber italiener
das ist natürlich weil man ist noch
heute so er kommt in die post und der
ruft jawala oder und danach strahlend
allen frauen an intention ist so
wunderschön aber das war total
gefährlich für die schweiz wir haben
gedacht das ist der wahnsinn im als tee
alles machen
[Musik]
die italiener als konkurrenten der
schweizer männern auch nach
arbeitsschluss da verwandelte sich
manche südländischer fabrikarbeiter in
einen eleganten tänzer die wohnadresse
machte eine baracke sein
doch im ausgang zeigte sich der
gastarbeiter der hiesigen dame als
adretter mann von welt fremd laut und
sexuell omnipräsent so lauteten einige
vorurteile
wir sind sie denn mit diesen
italienischen eigenschaften zu
entwickeln
sie habe nicht italienische
eigenschaften geheiratet sondern ich
habe meine liebe endet das war total im
hintergrund das war keine dass seine
frage ob ich nicht gehabt also sonst
wäre es nicht gegangen
das geht nur in einer ausschließlichkeit
jeweils ende jahr kam es an den
schweizer bahnhöfen zu einem großen
exodus zehntausender von italienern
reisten zurück in ihre heimat
saisonniers die nicht länger als neun
monate in der schweiz arbeiten durften
ihnen war es verboten die familie
mitzunehmen
ziel dieser politik war die wirtschaft
mit den notwendigen arbeitskräften zu
versorgen ohne dass sich die
fremdarbeiter in der schweiz integrieren
konnten
[Musik]
ich fahre nach italien zu meiner frauen
zu meinen drei töchtern ich meine kinder
habe ich nun seit zehn monaten nicht
mehr gesehen
mein kleiner sohn ist viereinhalb jahre
alt und heißt augusto neun monate lang
habe ich meine familie nicht mehr
gesehen
auch der vater von luis scola arbeitete
als saisonnier in der schweiz zehn
jahren ohne seine familie
dadurch dass mir dran von fünf wochen
sind in italien saison ist sicherlich um
zu mir dann können aufwachsen hat so die
entfernung zwischen ihm und louis und
der erzeugnisse aus gewöhnen und hat
sich aber nie richtig schönes gröne und
ich auch keine hilfe unterstützen
also das ist natürlich wollen wir
familien der kth werden auch eigenartige
die ausländer waren in der schweizer
politik nun zum streitfall geworden die
ängste vor dem fremden entfacht auf die
erste überfremdung initiative von james
schwarzenbach folgten in den nächsten
jahren weitere alle wurden abgelehnt nun
auch mit den stimmen der schweizer
frauen
eklat bei der nationalen aktion im
oktober 1970 die parteileitung muss der
bekannt geben dass präsident schwarzen
war die partei verlassen werde
begründet wurde der streit damit dass
man uneins über den zeitplan für eine
neue überfremdung initiative doch
offenbar war dem egozentrischen
schwarzenbach mitstreiter valentin oehen
zu mächtig geworden
umgehend gründer der schwarzenbach eine
neue rechte partei die von ihm absolut
dominierte republikanische bewegung
ideologischer taktgeber war seine
zeitung der republikaner
noch im jahr der gründung 1971 trat er
wieder zu den nationalratswahlen an und
wurde erneut gewählt
ganz vom einzelnen sondern sogar die
eigene stadt wirkung von der schweiz ins
spiel
nie zuvor war ein schweizer politiker
medial so präsent wie james
schwarzenbach
er war der erste medien es nach der
schweizer politik schwarzenbach warnte
sein publikum vor den fremden vor der
uno die er als korrupten [ __ ] flug
bezeichnete vor der in brüssel europa
dass er als suspekten laden empfand
erster august auf der zürcher von james
schwarzenbach war auf der höhe seiner
macht so berühmt wie in jenen jahren nur
noch skirennfahrer bernhard russi der
anlass war reich ausgestattet mit
vaterländischen requisiten die
vergangenheit als wegweiser in die
zukunft als neues feindbild gesellte
sich zu den ausländern nun der staat mit
seinen repräsentanten
angefeuert zeigten sich ob diese worte
nicht nur schwarzen was getreue sondern
auch einige störenfriede am rande des
festes
[Musik]
doch mit diesen wurden die verärgerten
patrioten schnell fertig 1974 lancierte
schwarzenbach eine nächste überfremdung
initiative sekundiert wurde er in jenen
jahren von seinem sekretär dem jungen
ulrich schnurr der heute bei der svp in
vorderster reihe gegen das fremde in all
seinen erscheinungsformen kämpft er
bewunderte schwarzenbach für dessen
ideen doch als sekretär dieses mannes
stand er auf verlorenem posten
organisation anspricht
als erste konsequenz die einzel gab sie
begegnet ist
fielmann hat man müsse feststellen wie
möglich organisatorische aufbau der hat
hin dass ich vor 2 wieder abgebrochen
was man vorher baujahr 1978 trat james
schwarzenbach mit 67 jahren aus der
politischen rampenlicht zurück so
schnell der erfolg gekommen war so rasch
verblühte die neue rechtsaußen partei
das große geltungsbedürfnis schwarzen
wachs hat dessen eigener partei
schließlich zerstört wie sein früherer
mitstreiter valentin oehen heute
feststellt
sehen die persönliche celtic wieder
hochbringen und das hätte mit einer
republikanischen bewegung versucht
machen die alle übrigen sowohl ruiniert
die größte stadt sydney
das macht ja in der appetit einfach
versucht zu manipulieren
e'dena lokale der kantonalvorstand die
selbständigkeit zugestanden
wenn die aber not immer in der bestimmte
wasser überschwemmte gebiet haben wir
die meine kinder da hätte sie halte aber
kunst
[Musik]
was schwarzenbach nicht geschafft hatte
erledigte nun die wirtschaft ausländer
raus
mitte der 70er jahre kam es zu einer
rezession 250.000 ausländische arbeiter
erhielten die kündigung und mussten die
schweiz verlassen
die arbeitslosigkeit wurde exportiert
die schweizer arbeiter kamen
einigermaßen glimpflich davon
die bewirtschaftung der ausländerfrage
war nun vorerst kein politisches
erfolgsrezept mehr
[Musik]
das änderte sich in den 80er jahren in
bern waren tamilische flüchtlinge in die
einstigen baracken der saison ließ
eingezogen
die asylanten dunkelhäutig und sehr
fremd boten sich als neues
ausländerprobleme sie war es auch die
flüchtlinge dass sich flüchtlinge sich
auf staatskosten schweizer ferien machen
auch pensionist schwarzenbach ließ sich
dazu an seinem alterssitz im engadin
vernehmen
wir rannten egoist sein wenn man sich
schnell heraus sie mit ihren könnten
damit assimilieren vietnam es nicht aus
sie mit ihren ich bin dafür dass die in
absehbarer zeit wieder heim und wird der
mine ist das überhaupt kein problem da
der tarifvertrag des release hat gesagt
dass sie genauso wirtschaftsflüchtling
dass ich die flüchtlinge die hörner thai
und das passieren erneut in den 90er
jahren verstärkte sich die immigration
neue flüchtlinge aus dem balkan
erreichten die schweiz ein neuer
politischer akteure nahmen sich der asyl
und ausländerfrage an wenn ich das thema
über freunde genau für sie zum thema
wurde
also ich an ihr vorüber wenn die grid w
sie sollen begriff wenig näher
eigentlich trägt hat die überfremdung
sondern es ist also masse nicht viel
aktiver andere also ich aber schon
besonders mehr
hauptproblem ist nach einer für reisende
wurde in den neunziger jahren dass sie
das problem der zürcher svp-nationalrat
christoph blocher ein erfolgreicher
vermögende unternehmer wurde nun zum
anführer ein
breiten front gegen das fremde von viel
folklore um rand bejubelt von seinen
anhängern sogar im jahre 1995 durch die
zürcher innenstadt und gegen eine
annäherung der schweiz an europa zu
kämpfen
blocher und seine svp fürchten fortan
einen unerbittlichen kampf in
schwarz-weiß hier die guten rechten
schweizer an der gegendemonstration die
heimat müden die linken und netten die
neue aggressivität in der schweizer
politik trieb links und rechtsaußen auch
einige schwachköpfe auf die straße
44 jahre nachdem die erste überfremdung
initiative von james schwarzenbach knapp
gescheitert war war die svp für ihre
initiative gegen die masseneinwanderung
weniger radikal die forderung doch
ähnlich im ziel am neunten februar 2014
konnten die svp anhänger einen
abstimmungssieg feiern einen knappen 2
doch womöglich historischen sieg denn
die verlangte begrenzung der zuwanderung
stellt die bisherige zusammenarbeit mit
europa fundamental in frage
es war der triumph von christoph blocher
dem unangefochtenen wortführer der
rechten volkspartei asyl und russland
fragen politischer renzi weltmarkt
schwarze machen so sachsens prozent zu
erwarten
teilweise waren und weiter versprach sie
wie fühlt sich christoph blocher
schwarzenbach verbunden
raphael selbständig über zügig und mit
uns karriere bringt für der sache bis
macht und ehre wirklich schweiz schweiz
im kopf kraft ist und schweiz gange und
so während als einzige mannschaft als
ich mich auch für tweets setzen
schwarzenbach gemeinsamkeiten sind
unübersehbar zwei einzelkämpfer gegen
das fremde für den alleingang der
schweiz medien stars ihre zeit
vieles verbindet sie einiges trennt die
beiden sie bewirtschaftet skurril thema
bloch profitiert davon dass das problem
nicht gelöst worden sind und dass es
auch sehr stark sprochen unter dem
gesetz sind gut die redner also wieder
im volkacher mit nicht der
schwarzenbacher sehr gute demagoge
sportgerät maxi und frisches der
schwarzenbach geht an ihren eine
politische bewegung bringen wo er von
der stadt dadurch mehr in einzelne figur
xiii und niederklein führen also partei
so präge wenig sorge macht der svp dass
die kölner zwei historische figuren
vermutlich und zimperliche missionare im
besitz ihrer wahrheit unbeirrbar im
urteil
zwischen richtig und falsch große
unterschiede schwarzenbach het volk
scharf verachtet und - eine gnade
christoph blocher hat sie gern
der große unterschied zur
schwarzenbacher schwarzenbach nicht mit
dem gedanken auch rentiert hat das land
zu übernehmen und das lange du
verdächtige werde führe also vorhanden
ist um 8 unterscheidet
italienische saisonniers auf schweizer
strassen im streit für bessere arbeits
und lebensbedingungen
solche bilder weckten damals bei den
einheimischen die furcht vor kommunismus
und klassenkampf auch sehr giovanelli
der gewerkschafter marschierte mit bei
der politischen arbeit hatte er seine
spätere frau judith blogger kennen
gelernt der linke fremdarbeiter und sein
schwager christoph anführer der rechten
schweiz gibt es da überhaupt eine
verständigung aber wie immer die gleiche
meinung wurde aber menschlich stimmt mir
ein vorbilder dem blog ist ein vorbild
was sie aus linker aktivist und
gewerkschafter er hatte seine vier
kinder
die perle ersuchen sie sind nicht in den
raum gefallen sind sie nicht die in der
arbeitslosigkeit gefallen sind sie nicht
sind alle heute leite alle vier leitern
eigene betrieb hatte mir nicht abgelehnt
der schafft die blochers eine familie
zwei sichten auf die recht früher gesagt
die ist eigentlich schon in ordnung
meint ich bin ja sehr viel älter als er
und eigentlich hohe stücke auf mich gab
aber sie ist halt verdorben worden von
der sozialarbeit hat er dann gesagt
und heute
für ihn auch zu diesen soft die leuten
die einfach zu den netzen zu denn ja ja
ja ist aber kein kompliment nein das ist
überhaupt kein überhaupt kein kompliment
das ist sogar eine ganz scharfe und ganz
ungerechte beleidigung
[Musik]
eine pferdedressur zur einstimmung auf
die generalversammlung der schweizer
bodenleger in ein kontrastprogramm
könnte man sagen denn was anschließend
dieser gast zu berichten hat hat nichts
mit tresor zu tun eher mit dem gegenteil
davon mit der entfesselung aller
marktkräfte wirtschaftsprofessor donato
scognamiglio immobilienspezialist
berichtet von einer schweiz die an ihren
erfolg zu ersticken droht heißt die
lösung einen berg oder eher europa park
oder gibt es vielleicht auch etwas
dazwischen
der mann der hier das dilemma der
schweiz anhand der schwindelerregenden
zahlen des immobilienmarktes schildert
ist ein secondo sein vater war
franziskaner mönch ins jena als sich
eine schöne schweizer touristin namens
müller in den jungen mann verliebte die
liebe die sich nicht aufhalten
in bern begann der emigrant als
tellerwäscher war fabrikarbeiter ein
kämpferischer gewerkschafter auch die
familie wuchs donato kam als letztes von
sechs kindern
mittlerweile ist der see kondo professor
geworden und hat vielleicht eine idee
wie die bedrängte schweizer seele wieder
etwas frieden finden könnten
[Musik]
meine blogs und er hat immer noch nicht
unbedingt dichter stress oder wir
versuchen aber stets weniger attraktiv
zu machen beispielsweise
wirtschaftsförderung betrieben ist stolz
sie wenn wir wieder firma roxio weiter
nach wie mit der stille für die firmen
größter region erhält einen für ihre
unternehmen heute in der schweiz die
ausländer zu sündenböcken zu machen das
land abzuschotten solches gehört nicht
zu den rezepten von donato scognamiglio
jeder zweite frankreich und russland wo
sehr gut die erfahrung gemacht hat mit
osram der mit zuwanderern den ruhen
industrie in der forschung alles mit
stolz und ich glaube michael das fördert
die halle mit specials aus der routine
für den standort dass wir wieder
attraktiv blieben
das kann ja mir ist heute mitbesitzer
einer beratungsfirma im
immobilienbereich 64 mitarbeiter seine
herkunft allerdings hat er nie vergessen
sie macht ihn hellhörig gegenüber
rassismus findet er denn die schweiz
besonders fremdenfeindlich natürlich kam
auch das finde ich überaus gibt es eine
braune brotes und der unabhängig was
wasserschlacht finden ist einfach davor
bewirtschafter denn das auch tut spieler
mit einem stimm ich mache das darf man
nicht und das waren nicht
unverantwortlich fremden feinde waren
einst mitstreiter von schwarzenbach dann
dessen konkurrent am rechten rand er
selbst sieht sich nicht als feind der
ausländer sondern als grünen kämpfer
gegen die überbevölkerung
er ist einer der frühen väter der
radikal
ökologische nico popp initiative die
eine extreme beschränkung der
zuwanderung verlangt wieviel xenophobie
steckt in all diesen überfremdung ciney
ziehen oder wo schlechte erfahrungen
gemacht hätten und entsprechend reagiert
aber ich schätze sind im erster prozent
aber mit einem sieg rechnet mit der zeit
jede politische bewegung gerechnet mit
der er wohl nie hat nicht weißt du das
sinnvoll wenn sie sich so gestrickt dass
man sich verdienen distanziert hat was
bringt das
radikalisiert müsse aber aber sie hat
sich nick wirth aus dieser fremde kinder
mit marschieren wir werden halt die
suomi marschieren die andere die die
große parteien die klassische partei die
hängt das problem ganz einfach weg
diskutiert ja gar keine chance kam mit
anderen gruppen gewerbe oder bisse
reiche zwar nicht kann wie frau funke
studieren mit einigen oma anschlag etwas
man muss mit einer rate ja so meint er
man wird sich für sie die sache aber das
ist nicht grundsätzlich freunde finden
lichts er im land das lied freunde
wichtig sind
sérgio vannelli ist längst schweizer
geworden das vor 40 jahren hierzulande
italiener verachtet worden sind weiß
heute kaum mehr jemand so schnell
wechseln die sündenböcke um italiener
ebenfalls wurde nicht gestritten als im
februar 2014
die svp initiative gegen die
masseneinwanderung an die urne kam ich
habe auch einige ein gewisses
verständnis für viele leute die ja
einlegten
für mich ein großer unterschied zu den
70er jahren ist das im moment zahllose
schweizer angst haben um ihre existenz
also wir haben einen der gelockerten
kündigungsschutz
das ist ascot und wohin ging die stimme
von selbstschutz vannelli dem einstigen
fremdarbeiter aber nach gebrauchen sie
zugestimmt
nicht weil er ja vorher gesagt die
geschichte meteor oder hast du das jetzt
sie habe nicht um frieden haben gesagt
das war furchtbar
ich werde jetzt nicht schön
[Musik]
unsere hamburg
und das macht ihnen ein weniger angst
wir haben nick bedenken ich kann mich
heute denkt an die an die generation von
morgen übermorgen
vor 40 jahren war er selbst noch ein
fremder
damals hatte er angst vor dem mann der
hier begraben liegt zusammen mit seiner
frau hat sehr giovanelli das grab von
schwarzenbach in sankt moritz besucht
ich wollte im grunde wie eine späte
rache über diese figur warum es
eingesperrt gewesen ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]